[Music]
so my name is Liz Seward
I'm a senior strategist at Airbus um and
I'm here with some colleagues from the
space industry who introduced themselves
as we go along we are here to tell you a
little bit about how you land on another
planet so where have we been so far we
have landed technology safely and
successfully on two planets two moons
two comets and three asteroids so the
planets we've been to are Venus where
there are ten Russian Landers Mars which
is exceedingly difficult to land on
Russia has successfully landed one
mission which lasted fourteen and a half
seconds only but America's had a lot
more success there are five NASA Landers
and four NASA Rovers currently on the
surface and the Earth's moon is
obviously the most famous place that we
have landed there are 12 Landers from
Russia Canada and the USA and of course
people 12 people with three crewed
Rovers they drove across the planet
the Russians have also landed three
uncrewed Rovers which trundled around
remotely controlled from Earth so we've
also been to Saturn's moon Titan the
cassini-huygens Huygens was the lander
built by the European Space Agency to
comets NASA landed on one and the
Europeans we built the rosetta mission
with the feel a lambda which bounced
three times across the surface and ended
up in a crater but it did do a little
bit of science so we count that as a
success
Rosetta ended up on the comet but we we
crashed it into it at the end of the
mission so that one doesn't really count
and then asteroids nASA has landed on
one and the Japanese have landed on two
so to tell us how we design some of
these missions I'm going to hand over to
Ellie Alois Thank You Liz good afternoon
everyone my name is Ellie a Lewis worked
as part of their future programs at
Eva's and I'm the robotic systems team
leads so lives introduced already
Summerson the exciting destinations
where
very keen to investigate and we have
investigated already our mission is
really to support the space agencies
like UK say European Space Agency ESA to
turn all these different concepts into
reality from really science fiction into
engineering facts and overall is is
twofold first we form of most like a
top-down definition of the mission
concept but also a bottom-up
developments of these technology the key
critical technologies and usually this
is done in partnership with academia and
SMEs as you may know and you see maybe
the tent at the very end we are very
much involved in the development of the
ExoMars Rover this is really led from
from the UK for the youth of the rover
itself it could be launched in July 2020
and it's been it's like a a laboratory
on wheels going to Mars and explore
search traces of life it's been fully
kitted out with a suite of instruments
and also for the first time we'll have a
two meter drill that will be able to
probe the AB the ground and to go you
know in the layer that we think is
pitiable favourable for current and past
places of life potentially currently
there's a a there's always a
communication delay with with Mars
between 3 and 21 minutes one way so you
can't really operate it like real time
and this is why we embed a lot of
autonomy into these platform these
rubbers to perform complex operations
without the need of an operator for
example and this particular Rover is
going to be able to run like without an
operator telling it where to go going
from A to B in the challenging
environment currently as you can see on
the picture on the left the rover has
been fully integrated and shipped to
France for final testing so it's really
critical time right now we're not
interested only in the nuts and bolts
and we've been conducting a number of
studies and project for ISA looking at
how you actually operate these kind of
platforms on other planets and we've
conducted a number of field trials to
provide realistic mimicking realistic
mission emulation for our engineers and
scientists to understand how to operate
how to improve the efficiency of the
operation of these platform on the
planets the next big goal is going to be
a returning examples from Mars it's
always very nice to actually study them
in situ but we'll need to actually bring
back these samples to actually get more
data out of them and the next big
milestone for planetary exploration is
going to be a mass of a return mission
and currently we are very much involved
in a ISA NASA cooperation to try to make
an build a new river that will be able
to collect a number of sample tubes that
will be deposited on the surface of Mars
next year and we'll need more autonomy
more to address some of the challenges
of the autonomous pickup and driving on
the landscape so in terms of actually
exploring all these different
environments first thing is you have to
survive and if you look at the long list
on the right there's lots of things that
could that could really prevent you from
doing so first you have to survive the
launch shocks and vibrations radiations
but from the way to your target and
actually as your break their family
extremes say between like minus 200 to
plus hundred degrees on the moon and of
course whether you're actually operating
in vacuum or with an atmosphere at where
the various dust that is corrosive that
is magnetic and so on and you could
depending on destination come across
liquids such as the oceans on Europa or
methane lakes on Titan so all of these
different environments I will actually
drive the design of ease of these robots
these are explorers in terms of material
selections and Steven will talk about
that a bit later it terms of what kind
companies you can actually use into
these missions and of course how you
operate them the operation of each
platform they really depends on the
complexity of operations and the
communication latencies
we can actually investigate we currently
investigate things anything between ten
operations were in the pareto and a
joystick almost to a flute animus and
rubber platforms and this is on the left
there an experiment we run with a
British had a stroke team peak when he
was on board the International Space
Station where actually took control of
one of our rubber platforms in a very
dry mass child to explore a mockup cave
or crater we've actually no prior
knowledge whatsoever about the
environment and that really was a
provided valuable insight into the human
factors sitter awareness and we're human
operators and eternally can actually
work in in synergies and of course we
talk about all and all of these
different elements landed them on planet
so first of all you have to survive the
landing and this is where I can have
Hannah to to carry to talk to the world
the landing system Thank You Lee my name
is Kerry sands I'm the Operations
Director for MDA UK we're a company
based in Harwell which is a science and
innovation campus in Oxfordshire you can
see that big round picture in the middle
that's the Harwell campus and we
specialize in design and manufacture of
sensors and communication payloads for
spacecraft and one of the coolest parts
of my job is that I'm involved in the
lunar resource mission so this is a 3d
printed model of a lunar resource this
is the Russian lambda that's scheduled
to launch in 2023 and it's going to the
South Pole of the moon and as part of
this it's going to go and look for water
and other resources that could
potentially be useful for future human
exploration we are providing the
autonomous landing a component of the
autonomous landing system for this
Lander which is being developed by
Airbus and what we are providing is the
lidar a lidar is kind of like a radar
but using pulses of light instead of
radio waves so our instrument will send
pulses of light to the surface and
measure the time for this to come back
to the instrument and then week
use that to measure distance and as we
scan the poster right across the surface
we can build a 3d map like one you can
see on the screen and this is run
through software and we try to figure
out where the safest places to land so
Green is a safe area and red it's not
safe
so we perform one scan at around 2
kilometers the land is moving at around
17 meters per second and we scan an area
around 300 by 300 meters which is the
equivalent of 9 football pitches and we
perform this gun in five seconds and
then based on this the lander will
[ __ ] it and aim for the safest spot it
will continue its descent and then at
200 meters it will perform another more
high-resolution scan and once again it
will look for the safest area to land
and the reason for using the lidar on
this is we're going to look for water
Vella tiles on the South Pole which is a
very rocky and area full of craters so
it's quite a dangerous area to land so
an autonomous system makes this much
safer now as Ellie said we have to try
and take into account a lot of
challenges when we're designing for
space missions so vacuum high ranges of
temperature the radiation environment
since we're leaving the protection of
the Earth's Van Allen belts and we also
have to make sure that we're extremely
reliable so it's a critical critical
system for landing and part of the way
we do this is we do a lot of testing on
the ground so you can see on the scene
we've performed tests at very long
runways to make sure that we can
actually correctly identify safe areas
we've also used the lidar on a robot arm
which simulates the conditions of the
lander as it's defending so we shake it
around a lot and then we generate scans
like the one on the right to make sure
that we are correctly selecting a safe
landing zone we also have to be very
careful that we select the right
materials to ensure that things like the
optics are not degraded by
the electronics are not going to stop
working there in different temperatures
or in vacuum and also making sure that
our materials for our structure not
going to distort thermally and throw out
our measurements so to talk a little bit
more about the material side of things
I'll hand over to Steven thank you oh
I'll use that thank you my name's Steven
company I'm managing director of tae
sik's limited we make advanced materials
so most people are familiar with carbon
fiber very strong very stiff well we do
the same sort of thing putting ceramic
fibers into titanium or aluminium very
very strong very stiff structures
ideally suited for a space missions and
space environment we're quite quite good
at this and we're unique we're the only
company worldwide doing this so working
with companies like Airbus is fantastic
for us to to get the applications just
to give you some idea of what that
really means because I can tell you in
kilos and Newtons and various other
units but this little tube here it's
about eight inches long 200 millimetres
whatever size you want to use weighs
about 35 grand same as a packet of
crisps you could balance well if you
could balance some safely to Range
Rovers on that without breaking it
I haven't yet had the chance to try but
maybe one day but that's just how strong
that that sort of tube is so ideal for
space missions so we've been doing a lot
of worker making pressure vessels and
fuel tanks for space systems parts for
aircraft landing gear and through making
the tubes for landing gear we've got the
opportunity to work on robotic arms so
we've done a number of programs with
with Airbus and with Ellie
the main one that we've been doing is
one called the lair o project which is a
large arm so this this arm here designed
to lift quite large loads for its size
in a space environment we did some very
clever things here we made that the arm
in one piece
we added some 3d printed everyone's
heard of 3d printing hopefully so where
you use metal to melt metal to the
direct shape of the final part that was
made by one of the partners on the
program and then we bonded it directly
to our tube to give us the stiffest
lightest structure we could possibly
manage and then le and the rest of the
team built that up into a robot arm
hopefully yes we have a video of the
system now so challenges of space for
materials are it's very expensive to get
into space so between 10,000 and 50,000
per kilo you put into space that's
really expensive the Mars missions are
at the upper end of that lunar missions
are at the upper end of that so you want
to take out as much weight as possible
and that's where our materials come in
the other thing is it's it's very very
harsh environment there's lots of
radiation so you need materials that
won't get damaged by radiation there's a
lot of heat change so minus a hundred
degrees to plus maybe 200 degrees that's
really quite challenging for materials
because they'll expand and shrink at
that temperature and you don't want
sensors like the lidar being five
millimeters out because that's a big
difference at two kilometers if you're
picking a safe landing site so our
materials are very stable ceramics in
them keep them very stiff and very
stable so we can do lightweight
materials we can do net shaped materials
that make them easier to make a lighter
to make and and more robust for the
final part and you end up with arms like
this which are about as compact and
about as Lices you could possibly make
to fit inside a spacecraft and land on
the Mars or on the moon so brilliant
opportunity for companies like mine and
a great opportunity for the UK I'll hand
you back to this
thank you very much so that's just a
little flavor of some of the engineering
challenges that we have to overcome and
some where are we going next or what are
we working on so we've heard about the
Landers on the Moon and Mars
there's also plan to send people back to
both of those planets and so we're
working on a space station to be in
orbit around the moon so that we can
have a more sustainable human presence
and NASA are taking the lead in that
Phillips at our worldwide effort and and
then it in terms of other robotic
missions Jupiter has a moon called
Europa which has an icy crust and
probably a water ocean underneath so a
very good place that we might find signs
of life so there are missions looking at
how we get there we also have the
Saturn's moon Titan so we we sent the
Huygens Lander there and it lasted at 90
minutes so we'd like to go back and the
plans are to have a hovercraft so it can
actually travel across the surface
because it's surfaces mostly methane
lakes so not very easy to land on and
and Venus so the idea is to have a long
duration lamda which is 24 hours so it's
Venus is a really horrible place to land
it's a full of sulfuric acid and really
high pressures so the Landers don't last
very long so so if we can get it to be
there for 24 hours a nice long time so
um thank you very much joining us and
please thank my panel motivates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you